Transcriber: Erman Turkmen
Gözden geçirme: Yunus ASIK
Ahmet Naç
Yeni Nesil Öğretmen
TEDxIstanbul.
Volkswagen Arena.
1-E
Cumhuriyet kuruldu 29 Ekim'de.
Meclis açıldı 1920'de.
Çanakkale Savaşı, 18 Mart.
Atatürk doğdu Selanik'te.
Atatürk sensin benim canım.
Babası, Ali Rıza Bey.
Annesi, Zübeyde Hanım.
1938'de kalbimizdedir.
Her 10 Kasım'da anarız seni.
Sonbahar, Kış.
İlkbahar, Yaz.
Dört tane mevsim.
Haydi sen de yaz.
Bir yılda 12 ay.
Haydi durma say.
Say say say say.
Ocak, Şubat, Mart,
Nisan, Mayıs, Haziran.
Durma haydi devam.
Temmuz, Ağustos, Eylül,
Ekim, Kasım, Aralık.
Liste hayli kabarık.
Ben birinci sınıfım,
okurum, yazarım.
Şehitlerimi anarım,
herkese saygılıyım.
Göklerde dalgalanır
gururla bayrağım.
TEDxIstanbul.
İşte ben buradayım.
(Alkışlar)
Cumhuriyet kuruldu 29 Ekim'de.
Meclis açıldı 1920'de.
Çanakkale Savaşı, 18 Mart.
Atatürk doğdu Selanik'te.
Atatürk sensin benim canım.
Babası Ali Rıza Bey.
Annesi Zübeyde hanım.
1938'de her sene,
her 10 Kasım'da anarız seni.
Teşekkürler.
(Alkışlar)
Buyurun.
Teşekkür ederim.
Harika.
Evet, şimdi bir hata yaptığımı fark ettim,
hemen onu paylaşayım.
Bu çocuklardan sonra çıkmak,
sanırım geçmişime baktığımda,
en büyük hatalarımdan biri olacak.
Galiba sönük kalacağım.
Şimdi buraya gelmeden
önce bazı mesajlar aldım.
Mendillerimizi aldık geliyoruz diyor.
Duygusal bir atmosfer olacak,
ağlayacağız gibisinden.
Öyle bir şey yok.
Gördüğünüz gibi gayet enerjik başladı
ve umuyorum da öyle devam eder.
Ben yine öğretmenlik yapacağım.
Sizler de kabul ederseniz
ilkokul öğrencileri olacaksınız.
Hiç vakit kaybetmeden başlayalım.
Size çok güzel bir masalım var.
Başlayalım mı anlatmaya? Peki.
(Alkışlar)
Şimdi efendim.
Çok uzun yıllar önce Dünya'da
çok kötü kalpli bir kuş yaşarmış.
Öyle ki Dünya'da yeryüzündeki
köyleri, kasabaları,
şehirleri, sarayları,
kaleleri bir bir yutmuş.
En nihayetinde bizim
toprakların üzerine gelmiş.
Tabii biz öyle kolay lokma değiliz.
Bakalım, işte.
Köylülerimiz. Direniyoruz.
Oklarımız, mızraklarımız ve
hatta hatta bir de topumuz var.
Ama şöyle de bir gerçek
var ki kuşumuz çok büyük.
Bakın kanatları her zaman yukarıda,
karizmasından ödün vermiyor.
Attığımız okların nasıl etki
bıraktığını görüyorsunuz.
Adeta onun için bir iğne geliyor.
Peki topumuzun etkisi nedir?
Ne yazık ki ona
siyah bir leke bırakmaktan,
sinek vızıltısı izi bırakmaktan
başka bir şey değil.
Evet, moralimizi bozmuyoruz.
Bir de kahraman köpeğimiz var,
hemen görelim.
İşte.
Köpeğimizin de ne kadar tatlı olduğuna
ve şirin olduğuna bakıp aldanmayın.
Kuş alçaktan uçtuğu sıralarda sol kanadına
yapışıyor ve onu asla bırakmıyor.
Bakın, nasıl konsantre bir
şekilde görevinin başında.
Hatta kanadının oradaki o kırmızılık
onun aslında bir damarıdır.
Kanadı enfeksiyon kapıyor ve kuşumuz
sol kanadını kullanamaz hâle geliyor.
Tabii ki sağ kanadını kullanıyor.
Tabii bunun da bazı sonuçları var.
Sağ kanadını kullanmasıyla,
kuşumuzun o sağ kanadının
diğerine göre ne kadar
yıprandığını görebiliyorsunuz.
Tüyleri dökülmüş, eskimiş.
Hatta bunun da tabii bazı sonuçları var.
Denge problemleri yaşamaya başlıyor.
Tek kanatla uçması sebebiyle
konma problemleri yaşıyor
ve sakarlık ortaya çıkıyor.
Kanadıyla dağlara taşlara çarpıyor.
İşte anatomik sonuçlarından bir tanesi.
Buradan ne anlıyoruz?
Yani benim çizim konusunda ne kadar
yeteneksiz olduğum dışında?
Denge problemi yaşamış ve konma
bölümü tamamen değişmiş.
Oraya doğru bir adaptasyon var,
yani şöyle konuyor.
Tabii Türkçe'de bir tabir var bununla
ilgili ama şu an söyleyemem.
Devam edelim.
Kuşumuzla ilgili gizemini koruyan
en ilginç bilgilerden bir tanesi de
boynunda bir çanın asılı olması.
Tabii bunu kim taktı,
neden taktı, çeşitli rivayetler var.
Tahmin ediyoruz ki yavruyken takıldı,
insanlar sesini duysun,
uyarıyı alsınlar diye.
Devam edelim.
Tüm imkânları zorladık, kuşumuzun röntgen
ve ultrason görüntülerine ulaştık.
İşte bakın, kalbi diğer tarafta.
Halbuki solda olması gerekiyor.
Tabii bunu köylülerimiz bilmiyor.
Bilmedikleri için de bakın
mızraklarını nereye atmışlar.
Orasını ne kadar yıpratmışlar.
Biraz daha aşağı inelim.
Yemek borusu, aşağıya doğru
midesine kadar iniyor.
Orada gördüğünüz gibi bir kale var.
Kaleyi yutmuş, sadece ikiye bölünmüş.
Çiğnemeden yutuyor.
O kadar acımasız bir kuş.
Biraz daha devam edelim.
Belki sunumun başında bana inanmadınız.
Dediniz ki bir kuş nasıl şehirleri yutar.
İşte gerçek görüntüler.
Eski çağlardan kalma antik bir şehir
ve hemen yanında bir metropol.
Olduğu gibi duruyor.
Evet şimdi inandınız değil mi?
Biraz daha aşağıya inelim.
Onun en büyük avını göstereceğim size.
İşte, bir saray.
Koskocaman bir saray midesinde.
Lütfen saray yuttu diye kuşa karşı
bir sempati beslemeyin.
(Gülüşmeler)
(Alkışlar)
Evet, olduğu gibi midesinde duruyor.
Şimdi aklınızda şöyle bir soru var,
ya bu kuş hep taş toprak mı
yutuyor efendim?
Hayır.
İşte sucuk, işte pastırma.
Gayet dengeli ve düzenli besleniyor.
Evet.
Şimdi, burada masalımıza bir ara verelim.
Ben o sınıfı tasarladığımda
şunu düşünüyordum.
Okuma alışkanlığı,
benim için çok önemliydi.
Sanat çok önemliydi.
Spor çok önemliydi.
Müzik çok önemliydi.
Bunları yapacak yerlerim yoktu
ve sınıfı o şekilde tasarlamayı seçtim.
O sınıftan sonra işi duvarların
daha ötesine taşıdım.
Bu iş böyledir.
Bazen bir sınıf tasarlarsınız, bazen de
bir rap şarkısı yaparsınız.
O bilgileri çok sevsinler, o enerjilerini
atsınlar, ön yargılı olmasınlar diye.
Bazen de masal anlatırsınız.
Tıpkı biraz önce size anlattığım
masalda olduğu gibi.
Aslında biz biraz önce bir ders işledik.
Daha önce görmediği hâlde
fark eden var mı?
Yok mu?
Bakalım neymiş.
Evet, işte kuşumuz.
Kanatları yukarıda, kuyruğu ve başı.
Tanıdık geldi mi?
Yok mu?
Bravo! İç Anadolu Bölgesi.
Kuşumuzun boynunda ne vardı?
Bir çan değil mi?
Hatırlıyorsunuz.
İşte, orada.
Çankırı.
Köpeğimizi hatırlıyor musunuz ,
kahraman köpeğimizi?
Hemen sol kanadını ısırmıştı değil mi?
Tabii köpek bizim köpeğimizse
Kangal köpek değil mi?
Sivas Kangal.
Diğer kanadı kullana kullana
çok yıpranmıştı ve eskimişti.
İşte orada.
Peki ayaklarını hatırlıyor musunuz?
Tövbeler olsun o ayakları
unutmak mümkün değil.
Hatırlıyorsunuz değil mi?
Konma bölümünü hatırlıyorsunuz?
Konya.
Peki okların bıraktığı etkiyi
hatırlıyor musunuz?
İğne gibi gelmişti.
İşte burada bir kafiye var.
Peki topların bıraktığı o kapkara
lekeyi hatırlıyor musunuz?
Ben buna Karamen diyorum,
bir gün açıklarım.
Peki kalbi?
Diğer taraftaydı.
İşte orada Ankara.
Diğer tarafının da mızraklarla
ne kadar yıprandığını
ve yozlaştığını hatırlıyorsunuz değil mi?
Evet, Yozgat.
Midesine indik.
Kale vardı.
İkiye bölünmüş bir kale.
Kırık bir kale.
Aşağıya inelim, şehirler.
İki şehir var.
Kır saçlı, antik bir şehir
ve hemen yanında bir metropol.
Ben ona Newşehir diyorum,
W harfinden göreceğiniz üzere.
En büyük avı tabii ki Aksaray.
Midesinde duruyor.
Tabii ki sucuk ve pastırma.
(Alkışlar)
Daha bitmedi.
Kanatları nasıldı?
Yukarıya doğru.
Peki kızıllık olan damarı
hatırlıyorsunuz değil mi?
Köpeğimizin olduğu yerde.
Yukarı Kızılırmak neresi olabilir?
Orası.
Sakarlığa yol açan, dağlara taşlara
çarpan kanadını da hatırlıyoruz.
Yukarı Sakarya.
Peki konma bölümü?
Konya bölümü.
Yukarı, orta, aşağı.
Yukarı Kızılırmak ve Orta Kızılırmak.
Amerika’yı yeniden keşfetmiyoruz ama bu
bir hafıza tekniği veya kodlama değildir.
Kodlama da bir düzensizlik, bir kaostur,
bir çeşit ezber yöntemidir.
Ben burada aslında bir sistemden
ve bir düzenden bahsediyorum.
Beş dakikada bu kadar.
Normalde burada çanı alıp
birinizin çalması gerekiyordu,
saldırıyı canlandırmamız gerekiyordu,
tek kanatlı uçmamız gerekiyordu.
Hatta ben buradan atlayabilirim.
Aslında hiç fena fikir değil,
gayet kalıcı olurdu.
Kuşu yatırıp otopsi yapmamız gerekiyordu.
İçine drama, gerilim müziği
katmamız gerekiyordu.
Böyle teferruatlar var.
45 dakika verin,
gayet yapayım size bunları.
Şimdi burada aslında
tüm bilgileri sistemli
ve düzenli bir şekilde
oluşturmaktan bahsediyorum.
Çünkü bizim beynimizin nasıl çalıştığına
dair bir fikrimiz var da
eğitim sistemimizde onun çalışma
prensiplerine uygun sistemlerimiz yok.
Aslında biz bildiğimiz
hiçbir şeyi unutmuyoruz.
Sadece bilgiye giden yolu kaybediyoruz.
Mesela Sivas Kongresi.
Hatay’ı hepiniz duydunuz değil mi?
Peki nerede beyninizde?
Nereye koydunuz?
Tıpkı bu bir masaüstü gibidir.
Bilgisayarın masaüstünü düşünün.
Bütün dosyalar karışıksa,
- hatırlayın vardır o, bilgisayarınız
bir dönem o hâli almıştır -
aradığınız bir dosyayı bulabilir misiniz?
Hayır.
Peki klasörler hâlinde düzenlesek,
belli bir sistematiği olsa,
tık tık tık tık hemen gider ve o
istediğiniz klasörü bulabilirsiniz.
Burada da bir temel attım,
bir ev inşa ettim, odalar açtım size.
Bu şekilde tüm coğrafi 7 bölgeyi,
içindeki bölümleri, şehirleri, dağları,
ovaları, gölleri, tarım ürünlerini,
yer altı kaynaklarını,
aklınıza gelebilecek her şeyi,
sadece sizlere değil,
tüm ilkokul öğrencilerine
-altını çiziyorum-
bütün öğrencilere hiçbir sorun
olmadan öğretebiliriz.
Her zaman bir yolu var.
Peki diyeceksiniz ki bu bizim
ne işimize yarıyor?
Aslında bunu bir sembol olarak düşünün.
Şimdi size bir soru sorayım.
Hepimiz üniversitelere gittik,
çeşitli sınavlarda kendimizi ispatladık.
Aranızda Mustafa Kemal'in
Samsun'a çıkışından itibaren
Cumhuriyet'in ilanına kadar
tüm olayları, kongreleri, savaşları,
çıkan gazeteleri kronolojik
olarak bana kimler sayabilir?
Şunu söylüyorum yani
bu bizi nereye götürecek peki?
Sınav olsaydı ezberlerdik, değil mi?
Ama sonra ne olurdu?
Hemen unuturduk, kullanıp atardık.
Peki biz bu coğrafyayı, bu tarihi
nasıl tartışacağız?
Nasıl konuşacağız?
Nasıl onunla ilgili kitapları okuyacağız?
En önemli soru şu.
Çocuklar bu dersleri nasıl sevecekler?
Biz çocukları hangi ders olursa olsun,
ilk derste %90’ınını kaybediyoruz.
Bir ön yargıyla -zor ders- ve bu
ezberleme yöntemleriyle.
Yani tüm dünyada milyonlarca öğrenci
içinden yıllarını bu işe vermiş
tarih profesörleri mi bunu yapar?
Bu kadar mı? Yıl olmuş 2016.
Bir avuç profesör mü bunu
sadece gerçekleştirebilir?
Hayır, itiraz ediyorum.
Gönüllüleri alabilir miyiz?
Hemen hızlı, süremizi yemeyelim.
Koş koş koş koş.
Mikrofonu alayım.
Bunlar 1. sınıf öğrencileri,
benim öğrencilerim.
Şu an gönüllü olanlar burada.
6 ve 7 yaşındalar.
Esenler'in bir mahallesinde
kura ile aldığım öğrencilerdir.
Seçme öğrenciler değildir.
Hemen soruyorum.
Mustafa Kemal’in Samsun'a
çıkışından itibaren
tarihte kronolojik olarak
kim bana ileriye gider?
Atatürk'ün Samsun'a çıkışı, Havza
Genelgesi, Amasya Genelgesi,
Erzurum Kongresi, Sivas Kongresi,
l. Türkiye Büyük Millet Meclisi açılışı,
l. İnönü Savaşı, ll. İnönü Savaşı,
Kütahya Eskişehir Savaşı,
Sakarya Meydan Muharebesi, Büyük Taarruz,
İzmir'in kurtuluşu, Mudanya Ateşkesi.
Tamam Mudanya Ateşkes Antlaşması.
Bravo, teşekkür ediyorum.
(Alkışlar)
Bakın, ezber değil ama ezberlemiş
gibi söylüyor değil mi?
Beynimizi biz doğru sistematik
şekilde organize edersek
beyniniz zaten size bu hızı veriyor.
Adeta o odaların içine girdiler ve yaşamış
gibi tüm olayları görerek söylediler.
Tıpkı siz evinizin içi, şu an evinizde
değilsiniz, evinizi hatırlayın.
Tüm odaları söylersiniz değil mi?
Mutfak, banyo, oturma odası,
hepsini söyleyebilirsiniz.
Neden? Çünkü görüyorsunuz, ezberlemediniz.
O zaman bu tarihi kronolojiyi
tersten de sayabilmeleri gerekiyor.
Ezberlemedilerse.
Kim Mudanya Ateşkes Antlaşması'ndan
itibaren tarihte geri geri gider?
Mudanya Ateşkes Antlaşması,
İzmir'in kurtuluşu, Büyük Taarruz,
Sakarya Meydan Muharebesi, Kütahya
Eskişehir Savaşı, İkinci İnönü Savaşı,
Birinci İnönü Savaşı, Birinci Türkiye
Büyük Millet Meclisi'nin açılışı,
Sivas Kongresi, Erzurum Kongresi,
Amasya Genelgesi, Havza Genelgesi,
Atatürk'ün Samsun'a çıkışı.
Teşekkür ederim.
(Alkışlar)
Ezber değil.
Tamamen olayları,
odaları görerek söylüyor.
Şimdi odaların içine girelim.
İrade-i Milliye gazetesi nerede çıktı?
Sivas Kongresi.
İstiklal Marşı nerede kabul edildi?
Kronolojiden bağımsız soruyorum.
1. İnönü Savaşı.
Peki Mustafa Kemal, her ilden
3 delegenin katılacağı
bir meclisin açılacağını
ilk defa nerede söyledi?
Siz seçin, hangisi olsun?
Amasya Genelgesi.
Manda ve himaye kesin olarak
nerede reddedildi?
Erzurum Kongresi.
Kaybettiğimiz bir savaş var mı?
Kütahya Eskişehir savaşı.
İstediğiniz kadar bilgiyi
düzenleyebiliriz doğru kullanırsak.
Bakın 6 ve 7 yaşındalar, hiç sorun değil.
Teşekkür ediyorum, hemen uğurlayalım sizi.
(Alkışlar)
Tabii bunlar gönüllü olanlar.
Şu an 3. sınıfa geçeceğiz, 3 ve 4'te tüm
tarih ve coğrafyayı bitirip tartışacağız,
araştıracağız, açık oturum yapacağız.
Yani seçilmiş öğrencilerle, üniversite
öğrencilerinin yapamadığını,
seçilmemiş her ilkokul öğrencisinin
yapabileceğini iddia ediyorum.
Dünya artık bunu başarmalıdır.
Bu, beynimizin tamamen
kullanımıyla alakalı.
Teklifim şu;
tüm üniversitelerdeki tüm bilgi, birikim,
sanat, müzik, spor, Türkçe, matematik,
tarih, coğrafya, fen,
aklınıza ne geliyorsa.
Seçilmiş öğrencilerin ulaştığı
seviyeyi, tüm birikimi alıp
tüm ilkokul öğrencilerine
vermeyi teklif ediyorum.
İlkokul bittiğinde en iyi üniversitelerin
en iyi öğrencilerinden daha yüksek
seviyelere çıkabileceklerini
iddia ediyorum.
Bu çocuklar bunları yapabilir.
Sahnede de yapabilir,
derslerinde de yapabilir,
aklınıza gelebilecek bütün yerlerde
bunları gerçekleştirebilirler.
Ortaokula geçtiklerinde yüksek lisansını
ve doktorasını yapsınlar.
Bakın 1 milyon çocuk varsa 1 milyonu da,
hiçbirini ayırt etmiyoruz.
Hiç fark etmez, hepsi öğrenebilir,
beyinleri varsa eğer ki var.
1 milyon tane kitap çıkacak demektir,
1 milyon tane proje çıkacak
demektir ortaya.
Hocam sen kendini ne zannediyorsun
diyebilirsiniz bana.
Bu, benim hedefim değil.
Ben aslında örnek aldığım
bir öğretmenin vizyonuyla,
onun hedefiyle burada konuşuyorum.
Kendisini hemen anlatacağım,
siz karar verin.
Bu hedefi koymakta haklı mıyım,
haksız mıyım?
Öğretmenimizin ismini bilmiyoruz.
Ancak onun bir öğrencisini tanıyoruz.
Hidayet Önder.
Yaşasaydı 106 yaşında olacaktı.
Sakarya Meydan Muharebesi'nin hemen
öncesinde, 1921 yılında ilkokul öğrencisi.
İşte onun öğretmeni.
Biliyorsunuz savaşın hemen ortasında
eğitim kongresi yapılmıştır.
Mustafa Kemal ve öğretmenler
şöyle bir karar almışlardır;
''Ne olursa olsun eğitim
çalışmaları devam edecektir.''
Mustafa Kemal savaşa gitmiştir,
oradaki öğretmenimiz de
Polatlı Karayavşan köyündeki
Obatepe'nin üzerine öğrencileriyle çıkar
ve hesap dersi işler.
Karşısında Duatepe var,
Mustafa Kemal orada.
Savaş devam ediyor,
yarın her şey bitebilir.
Hesap, uygulamalı matematik,
fizik, kimya, coğrafya
derslerinin işlendiği toptan bir derstir.
Gözle görülür bir mesafede savaş var.
Öğrenciler top namlusunun ağzından
çıkan ateşi görüyorlar.
Işığı görüyorlar.
Ses geliyor ve buna göre ateşin
düştüğü yeri hesaplıyorlar.
Çok samimi söylüyorum,
Hollywood bunun filmini yapsın,
yarısında çıkarım
böyle saçmalık olmaz diye.
Ama bu topraklarda bu yaşandı.
İşte benim bayrağı teslim
aldığım öğretmen o.
Öyle bir eğitim seferberliği
ve öyle bir eğitim başarısı ki
Dünya'da bir örneği daha yok.
Burada laf salatası yapmıyorum.
İşte, altta kaynak vardır.
200-300 yılda ülkelerin geldikleri
durumları görebiliyorsunuz.
O yıldızlı olan var ya, işte onlar
bu öğretmenler.
Bazı yerlerde yüzde 1, bazı yerlerde
binde 1 okuma yazma oranı var.
Bir ara %25'i yakalıyorlar, şu an hâlâ
dünya rekoru olarak kabul ediliyor.
Bakın bunu ne zaman yaptık çok önemli.
Bu insanlar bunlarla uğraşırken
çeyrek asır sonra, yarım asır sonra
Dünya'da Amerika ve Rusya kim daha büyük
atom bombası yapacak diye yarışıyorlardı.
Avrupa, Dünya ile birlikte milyonlarını,
tüm enerjisini, insan gücünü
savaşa ve ölüme harcıyordu.
Yükselen faşizmle birlikte gaz odalarında
fırınlarda, çoluk çocuk demeden yaktılar.
Japonya, ülkesinden uçak kaldırıyor,
okyanusu aşıyor ve başka bir ülkeye
kamikaze dalışı yapıyor.
Şimdi ben soruyorum; siz
''Yurtta barış, Dünya'da barış'' desenize.
Savaş zorunlu olmadıkça
bir cinayettir desenize.
Cumhurbaşkanı dâhil öğretmenden
sonra gelir desenize.
Eğitim kongreleri,
eğitim çalışmaları yapsanıza.
Hocam tartışmaya açık bir konu değildir.
Ülke olarak dünyada
eğitimde bir numara olalım.
Çağı yakalayalım.
Bu insanlar için, dünyaya bir asır
fark atmış bu insanlar için
böyle bir hedef çok küçük bir hedeftir.
Kabul etmiyorum.
Bizim hedefimiz sadece
kendi çocuklarımız değildir.
Bakın diğer ülkeler bizi anlamaz.
Onlar sonradan 70-80-90'da uyandılar.
Onların gidişatı kendi sınırlarını
çekmişler, hâlâ yurtta barış diyorlar.
Dünyada barış yok, çocuklara barış yok,
dünya çocukları yok.
Kendi sınırları içerisinde
eğitimcilik oynuyorlar.
Bakın onlar bu hedefi anlamazlar.
Bizler; benim hedefim, bizim hedefimiz
şu olmalıdır diye düşünüyorum.
Bu öğretmenden bayrağı teslim almış
bir öğretmen olarak.
Hem kendi çocuklarımız için,
hem de dünya çocukları için
sadece eğitimde bir numara olmak değil,
tüm bu eğitim sistemini yeniden
dizayn etmek ve eğitimde tüm dünyaya
çağ atlatmak bizim hedefimiz olmalıdır.
Her çocuğun ne kadar özel olduğunu
ve her çocuğa her şeyin aslında
öğretilebilir olacağının yolunu bulmak
ve bunu göstermektir.
Bugün bu yöntemleri kullanıyorum.
Sınıfta rap müzik veya size
anlattığım bu sistem,
yarın hepsinden vazgeçebilirim.
Başka bir sistem bulabilirim ama
bu hedefim değişmeyecek.
Hareketi başlatmayı, kuralları yıkmayı
ve onları yeniden yazmayı,
hayalleri gerçeğe dönüştürmeyi,
imkânsızı başarmayı
ve bunları yaparken ağlamamayı,
sızlamamayı, bahane üretmemeyi
ben baş öğretmenimden ve onların
öğretmenlerinden öğrendim.
Benim için hedef;
biraz önce söylediğim hedef,
size anlatmaya çalıştığım bu hedef
benim değil onların vizyonudur.
Bu aslında hepimiz için
geçerli olan vizyondur.
Bundan daha azı düşünülemez.
Benim için de daha azı yoktur
ve başka bir yolu da yoktur.
Çok teşekkürler, sağ olun.
(Alkışlar)